[Music]
restaurants are reopening
but it's far from business as usual
they now have to be covered secure that
means reduced space for diners
many of whom remain cautious about
eating out
this week we're at levan in peckham the
people who live in this residential
corner of south london will be crucial
if restaurants like this have survived
some restaurants are sitting tight
others have taken the plunge most
restaurants have been forced to adapt
their business in some way
lavan reopened as soon as it could on
july 4th but what does this new
indoor dining experience look like and
will the local community buy into it
so tim it's a few weeks now since the
big reopening in the uk
i saw restaurants bars cafes back in
operation
i still haven't been out to eat indoors
in a restaurant i don't know if i've
been too nervous
or what i went out on the first night um
not because i
wanted to but because i felt that i
needed to to find out what's going on
and be able to
so i think about it and comment on it
and since then i've been to several
places and the places that i felt good
about
there's been a kind of a thing of of
actually you found something almost
new in this one thing that's very new
about this place of course is the
complementary hand sanitizer that we're
seeing on every on every table
that wasn't here before before
disclosure this is a local restaurant
for me i live just up the road this is
your manner this is my manner welcome to
peckham i love this place but i do
wonder
what it's going to be like now with the
new restrictions part of his charm was
it was very cozy
very bustling you could get a seat at
the bar with the open kitchen around
you i'm just not sure how they're going
to be able to do that under the new
restrictions all of these houses around
us are full of people
locked down and happy and if they want
to go to a place they'll go locally
they'll go here
the van is the second restaurant from
executive chef nick and co-founder mark
they also own salon in brixton which has
a wine shop next door
it's going really good so far yeah it's
fully booked at 50 capacity and what
time do you open
5 30.
[Laughter]
what's the response been like so far you
said you fully booked tonight has it
been the case since we opened it
obviously we've got fewer tables um but
we've been we've been busy every night
we don't book out
the seats outside but when the weather's
good we're busy i live up to
the road from here this was my favorite
seat i wouldn't be able to sit
in it i don't think at the moment
because of the the one meter plus
restrictions right you've got four seats
here those seats are empty unfortunate
at the moment um
yeah it's a real shame i mean that was
my best my favorite seat as well it's
one of the compromises we've had to make
we've got we've got about 50 of the
capacity that we did have
um but i still feel like there's there's
an atmosphere here and there's a buzz
and
probably buoyed by the fact that people
are excited to be back out and eating
again
lockdown couldn't have covered a worse
time for mark and nick they were just
about to open a new bar and restaurant
next door to levant
we opened it the week of lockdown we
opened on the monday night
and we shut it on a thursday it was
pretty brutal
that must have been agonizing yeah it
was and of course
during that time people were starting to
self-isolate
so actually hardly any of our staff
actually came in to work it
and it was just matt nick and i pretty
much doing it
and then we had to make that you know
the call and closing it
um which is really hard we kind of went
into shock
and what's your landlord like very good
he's been very supportive
really yeah certainly you've had it
you've had a break on on
payments et cetera and that's that's
helping you through
our landlords here have been really
generous but loads of our overheads have
remained the same so whilst we're we're
our kind of food costs and our staff
costs are relative to our turnover
a lot of the other overheads are still
quite high
working with a forgiving landlord during
the crisis has been priceless
the restaurants have been under immense
pressure and mostly been forced to try
something new
for mark and nick it was delivering wine
and more recently take away meals
we've got a wine shop over in brixton we
went from doing no delivery at all to
doing 100 boxes a week i basically
packed it up and took it around london
in a car
so we all stayed at home and drank too
much and anybody who was going to supply
that need
because it was an essential service
right really absolutely it was almost
like
cooking fatigue i i feel during lockdown
i mean
the bread baking right everybody's
breaking bad for the first exactly
everyone became bakers and pasta makers
the novelty wore off and
and people were kind of itching to eat
the food of their favorite restaurants
and we decided to do a sort of takeaway
service really paired by us but there's
some finishing touches to do at home
we never thought we'd be a takeaway
restaurant or we had a takeaway arm
it was never our kind of gay goal um but
it's um it's allowed us to open another
revenue stream which is
really important especially in right now
where we look we're 50
down on our covers so we need that extra
income customers are afraid of going out
at the moment we're actually able to
service them as well
the future is frighteningly uncertain
the loyalty of its community
and how they work with it will become
ever more important for le then
we were restaurant operators who had a
place in central london i'd be quaking
in my boots at the moment that
marketplace particularly has changed so
dramatically
we've got you know an amazingly sort of
loyal band of regulars we feel
very lucky in that respect social media
is a huge tool for us we definitely see
when we put things on on those platforms
you get bumps in seats
i just wonder what kind of impacts kovis
had on the
supply chain everyone's been running on
the skeleton crew everyone's
turnover has dipped dramatically
everyone's customer base has shrunk
the supply chains have been affected and
all of our suppliers
further up the chain are asking for
payment up front and cafe is a big thing
in
any industry but particularly in the
restaurant industry where margins are
really tight
a lot of the big chain restaurants are
very loudly proclaiming that they're
going to pass on that reduction to the
customers
we can't simply can't afford to to do
that we've down 50
here we have been shot for you know
three and a half months four months it's
definitely going to be
a challenging period once summer's over
and we can't use the outside seats i
think four months or three months you've
kind of cooked yourself
has made everyone realize that how
special it is being fed by someone else
and being dying and being looked after
and you know the kind of the magic of
what restaurants are you know
come in and you have a great time and
you leave the smile on your face
it's early and the restaurant is still
quiet
when we sit down to eat we're presented
with a single use menu
we recommend five to six dishes between
the two of you makes the snacks and the
sharing
sharing does that still work do we share
do we share a place i don't know we
we have your own plates we won't be
feeding food into each other's mouths
deeply erotic but otherwise no
community is going to be a really really
key thing for restaurants i think when
we're looking at places like the city
and soho
the reason they're in trouble is they
don't have an immediate community that
makes
sense for them to lock into as for the
dining experience it sounds like
the feedback they've been getting has
been broadly positive they've got a lot
of local
people who come to the restaurant
regularly and they've been coming back
that's the bode well
they're under pressure so they're being
immensely creative
this could be an opportunity nick was
talking about the the take
out and diy thing they've started doing
and saying that they might even continue
that
when things go back to normal i'm not
sure anybody's gonna be able to turn
down any revenue streams
in any way at all over the next few
years i think there's enormous amount of
creative thinking going on they're
thinking really hard and they're gonna
have to right because i mean
no one has a crystal ball and this is
the same frame this is the same for
everybody i think it's changing week by
week
in the end it goes back to what delights
the customer and i think they're asking
themselves daily what it's gonna do
by customers it's better for all of us
in the long run
well this is for me delightful and as a
local i hope that they
do find a way to keep it going i agree
thank you for bringing me out
thanks for coming these are ridiculously
good they're very good right